first things first
you brought your mama you brought your
grandmama you brought the family did I
did that means you what does it mean to
you to be able to bring them all here
with they narrated my house my grandma
say Louis oh she's never flown I'm a
Missouri girl - yes I'm from Columbia
hey granny I'm from Missouri - that's
right I mean Your Honor Obama's playlist
I mean what will I be what was your
reaction you just you lost me hey that
like I literally I was in Hawaii and I
thought it was I heard then he was also
there and I was like a sign that I need
to stalk him like more evenly like I
don't know what this game started but I
I don't know like I just basically was
super I wasn't sure
that's like the only word I can think of
because I wanted so bad to meet him
while he was still in the White House
and I was like damn I haven't done
enough like I'm not I'm not cool enough
to meet him yet and somehow guys still
brought him to me
sunk in yet that you have five
nominations tonight five right but this
could really be your night we can't let
you walk down the red carpet without
asking about this incredible look you
have going on here I mean like Donatella
thank you for seeing something in me
she just custom-fit this dress and I
don't even know how I got the honor of
wings but such a good singer but my
favorite thing about that it makes me
look Nick you got that that's all you do
congratulations it's true you were
thinking about quitting the business and
then I don't know it's like you gotta
just pay attention to where God takes
you at night to wherever that leaving
sometimes not always music sometimes the
message is definitely you have to walk
through I'm walking I'm moving through
through in Versace Couture honey how the
nerd is doing performing tonight in
front of the who's who in music how you
feel and you ready
[Music]